roads to the top premieres on wednesday
september 29th at 10 p.m eastern time
and it's gonna premiere after yet
another action-packed episode of aew
dynamite the dynamite couple the stars
of that program
none other than cody and brandy rhodes
here on the rich eisen show together how
are you guys
hey how are you we're doing pretty good
i feel like a real regular on the show i
really feel great about that you should
yeah it's you you more than anybody you
know what
made me feel great
well i appreciate that i i feel like i
was there at the very beginning and that
if you
continue appearing you might actually
technically cody be a rich eyes and show
sidekick like you might actually
get in that territory not that that's
what that's aspirational in any way
there's nothing i want more than that
and
i love the fact that you were there in
the beginning because in the beginning
we were just talking out
of our ass basically about what
what this company would be and what
wrestling could ha and we we had big
high hopes and all the optimism in the
world but the fact that
it's happened with now two shows and
then this being a third show it is
what a season what a blessed time
well my first question is for the actual
rhodes who's a scholar brandy um
got him there you go there you have it
um so how did what what when were you at
the university of michigan when did you
go there what is your
oh my gosh so i graduated from u of m in
2005
i believe yeah so yeah i studied
communications there i had a full
academic scholarship
um which
was hard for me to believe
but but we did it um yeah and that's
that's my michigan story i'm from
michigan uh my parents live in canton
michigan which is about 25 minutes or so
from uh ann arbor and uh
was was born and raised in inkster
michigan so i'm a millionaire
yes now now um as of this recording the
university of michigan football team
in unblemished 3-0 right now
that is yeah that's i'm scared
okay
i'm happy but i'm afraid i feel like
they should be ranked ahead of ohio
state currently ohio state does have a
blemish on their record what did they
just go down to
oregon the same way that michigan beat
washington um so
yes
see and i
ohio state's terrible and most of the
fandom of ohio state's very mean to me
they're very pushy yeah you know my
brother's always you know what i'm i
need to text my brother i'm going to
text him now i'm going to say how about
that always just yelling ohio our lead
security guy sam is always yelling it
and then the fans yell it back
whatever my brother i'll get back to you
on it
i'm with you too now here's here's
something that's aspirational
i think you guys should get jim harbaugh
involved in the aew in some way shape or
form
your thoughts
your thoughts on that subject matter
i would have to defer to our football
our football guy in terms of tony khan
i gotta know what that relationship is
like because wait a minute that's right
so urban meyer
wait up now that was hold on a second
that was absolutely
fantastic
with jericho that was amazing
that was one of my favorite moments of
the entire summer
is watching a fight spill into
you know
and just totally random happened to be
urban meyer's office
utilizing a laptop handed to chris
jericho by urban mark that was genius
that was absolutely genius
it's amazing the synergy between because
we were in daley's place in the
amphitheater there connected to the
stadium for so long
the synergy between the jags and aw
that's our team now no matter what to a
degree even if you had a team prior this
has got to at least be your secondary
team and urban
tony has had urban frequently backstage
urban's got a presence like some of the
best pro wrestlers i've ever seen when
he walks by everybody just is at
attention he really
what a great leader
just really great leader yeah so but is
he aware of your guys michigan fandom is
he aware of that in any way shape or
form
brandi doesn't really bring it out she's
a quiet michigan michigan fan because i
don't like getting jeered if things go
wrong so
i get i just get really quiet because i
can start going because i'm a long time
uga fan and i really just wear that too
hard on my sleeve there's a lot of
barking i was gonna say where's where
the bark is there we go okay so
you know that's the dogs are my my guys
you know always well i'm i'm thrilled
that you're you're now out branching out
the two of you together
where did the concept of this reality
show and following you guys around
where did it come from who brought it to
you what are your thoughts on that give
me that so we've been talking about this
all day and i just realized that we have
it all wrong we've been saying the wrong
thing all day the reality on it is it
came from tony
tony is the original one that was like
we should do a reality show with you
guys where we do all you we show the
backstage and we show your lives that
was 100 tony and all day i've been
saying it was tnt's idea
either way well here's tony here's where
they got here's where they got us they
said it would be different than other
reality shows because you guys will be
producers i thought okay so we'll have
this element of control to it
no no this is
it's it's we they got us thankfully we
do have a lot of input but it's not as
easy of input as you thought like i
thought you know oh if i just say hey x
y and z
that would be the the case but i'll say
x y and z and they'll be like well what
about a b and c and then i'll be like
really
okay how about x y and z and what about
just z
and i'm like okay this is a debate
yeah a lot of a lot of hey guys don't
film this right now please and then
you'll see them 10 yards away with the
boom just fully extended
getting every bit of it like oh okay
well well never mind from a wrestling
perspective
they
this is the most unprecedented behind
the scenes access i have ever seen and i
feel like the super fan that aew's
really built on that hardcore fan in the
first place
i hope they they love what they see
there's a lot to learn just watching it
to see
how the management functions how these
characters all intertwine backstage it
really is something you would have never
seen in the in the
the yester years of wrestling happening
now
i've got cody and brandy rhodes right
here on the rich eisen show roads to the
top premieres wednesday september 29th
10 p.m eastern on tnt so
you know
from putting together that all-in event
back in 2018 to where aew is now how do
you
how do you
[Music]
rate the progress of your organization
does it blow you away
between those points a to the current
point b right now
i think maybe a really great indicator
of of where we've come is
all of the current free agents that tony
was able to acquire and wanted to sign
adam cole brian danielson and of course
cm punk returning to the ring after
seven years and falling back in love
with wrestling and you mentioned all in
that was a bet to see if we could sell
10 000 seats
this wednesday we're in front of 20
000 plus people in arthur ashe stadium
in new york city and that show sold out
without a talent attached without a
match announced
that's going to be a moment for all of
us to
old aw and new aw to kind of converge on
what's happened the idea we were an
alternative or a challenger brand an
underdog yes but
we're now dominating the space
and i'm almost scared of what i might
say next because everything i've said on
your show has has come true we've been
good luck for us
in terms of our our growth as a company
well i appreciate you even you know
recognizing what's called the rich eisen
show bump that's right
that's what it is
that's what it is that's what it was you
know it is
a move after you like call it the rich
eisen
okay i'm getting let's get it with the
rich eyes hit him with the eyes
hit him with the eyes and is a great uh
it's a great word what what does the
addition of cm punk mean
what would you say to that
i mean from a data standpoint every
record we have
he instantly broke i think we added 12
new servers to our our shop aaw.com site
in terms of the merchandise he was able
to to put out there the uh the ratings
you know they they come down to the
number one on cable series and it
averages a little over a million but if
you look at his segments specifically
they're they're nearing 2 million in
terms of a of overall views he really it
was a flash point in wrestling um every
wrestler
should know
the prominence he brings and the fact
that now he picks somebody like darby to
wrestle first picking new talent unsung
talent perhaps aew og homegrown talent
he knows exactly what he's doing and i'm
just excited to see him passionate about
wrestling again because the fans have
always been passionate about him
and that that's just uh you know
kind of a
a tribute to what we've laid out here to
see somebody like cm punk who who kind
of vowed to to step away and step away
from forever
to change his mind through this three
years of this process and come to a
place where he said okay i'm gonna try
this again um
that just shows
we've brought enough uh curiosity to
this we've we've had enough positivity
here we've we've had enough word of
mouth of that this is where
you can be you and you can do what you
love and have your passion again um him
coming on board i feel like it's a good
and a bad thing because everybody's
going to want to be here now um if if cm
punk
came back to come here
why wouldn't you want to bring him up
bring him on you know more more the
merrier right i guess that's one of
those good problems to have i'll be
honest with you uh cody and brandy
rhodes here on the rich eisen show
that
starting nfl network from scratch
you know i left espn in 2003 to to do
that you know left sports center and
and a lot of people wondering what the
hell are you doing you know and we
started from scratch
and i think when we first kind of what
you were just saying brandi about the
legitimacy
of what you've built
is
recognized and i guess in a way
um
legitimized also
by the fact that others
want to be part of what you've built
that it is something for their brand
to join yours
is something that makes sense
and it's something that is sort of
like putting you're in the back of the
checkerboard you've been king you know
on the back of the checkerboard there
that i just remember when folks like
dion sanders joined
nfl network chris collinsworth started
calling games for nfl network on a
thursday night which is a package that
the nfl decided to put there that kind
of told us that what we've built
is something that others view
as it's okay for them to join and
they're also eager to join
and that felt great i think that's kind
of what you're describing
right there oh 100 oh yeah
100 i
throughout the course of filming roads
to the top it's very
apparent that for three years i felt
like several of us have pulled the wagon
and been happy to do so and that was the
honor of our lives as wrestlers but
there's a lot of exhaustion that has
come with it too
and like you said the the legitim
the legitimization of of somebody like
punk somebody like brian danielson
coming here
oh
as the only scary thing is as a wrestler
as as an executive you can hang your hat
on that and say wow that's a this is a
great legacy but as a wrestler now you
have to find ways to get back in the
ring with those guys and on that level
and that just ups everybody's game
uh so what's next i guess my last
question for you where do you want to go
from here
um
first
sure
uh for me
i think we see a lot of
on roads at the top the question being
asked of me of okay well now that you're
a mother now
um how does your how did your life
change and my intention is
uh professionally for it to not change
um of course my life changed my life
changed immensely the second that she's
arrived
but
it's very important to me for her to see
her mother
still passionate about something
still having goals and working towards
goals
and
that is that is my goal that is what i
hope to continue to do um i say a lot on
roads to the top that i'll be back in
the ring um
i haven't been back yet but it's only
been three months so
i think it's okay um but i will be back
and uh i haven't stopped working as
chief brand officer i i had the i was on
the road and had the baby two weeks off
of coming off of my last flight uh so
that's a you know a testament to how
much i'm committed to that and working
um and uh
still still heavily working so um
my goal is to just be a role model to
her
show her
that you can have your passions you can
be a mother you can you can do whatever
you want to do
that was a a really long answer no but
cody i mean you can't top it you can't
top it i was i was honestly just stop it
you can't you haven't created life cody
i mean you know no
working but no go i'm still interested
in your answer
well
yeah i really can't top it i think
looking forward for us is i'd love to
get back in the picture for the tnt
championship i think that's the coolest
title the must-have title and all of
wrestling and i was fortunate enough to
be the first champion
on the other side of that on the
management side i got to start my own
department the community outreach
department with aew
and
that has been the most rewarding
aspect of the last year of aaw is to get
into these markets
that we're going to whether the cameras
are on our cameras are off and just do
something nice
for the local markets that we're hitting
in each and every town and getting
talent involvement from those who are
from there that's
been my favorite part whether it's the
food bank drive or tunnels for towers
like we're doing wednesday every market
a silent auction for el mac just
those things have
become probably my my number one
priority at aew just because i'm very
proud of that department
well uh congrats again on everything
going on with the aew on uh
and now roads from the top premiering
wednesday september 29 10 p.m eastern on
tnt the one hour premiere after
another action-packed episode of aew
dynamite
brandi and cody rhodes you have a spot
on my show whenever as you know thanks
for doing this again
thank you so much rich and just an
update from my ohio state fan fan
brother uh he just said a players slip
every now and then
look uh we don't have many legs to stand
on but um you know i'll i'll close with
this um
you know i i i've been fortunate to
emcee um a dinner at the pro football
hall of fame in canton ohio where i get
what you hear the o-h
and i respond when they say o-h and i
say n-o
that's how i respond uh but you know i
don't have much of a football leg to
stand on so
i'll make a joke like this like i did
this past time to a room full of ohio
people which shows i've got a little bit
of gumption and spine i told them that
there were 19 in chinese this year
because it was the combined for the last
two years together and just let them
know for the ohio state people in the
room that's the number between 18 and
20. wow
i have lived to tell the tale yes
good good good carry carry that you got
to get in their face sometimes yeah you
know carry that forward we need that we
need that we need that energy we're 3-0
right now
we need the energy for sure that's cody
and brandi rhodes right here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here